okay hey guys we are back playing more
man of Medan and I don't know about you
guys bye I have been wondering what is
places fate have we killed flesh what is
gonna happen well I don't know
now the GU at the moment but we're about
to find out I did get a comment last
time saying
yeah gran please keep your hand on the
keys because those QuickTime events come
out of nowhere and I know and I will try
but I'm just telling you this I can't
remember how until dawn was but I felt
with until dawn I actually knew when I
had to pay attention and when the
QuickTime events were about to happen
and here I don't I don't know what
happened but it's designed in a way that
it just comes out of nowhere
and there's no forewarning we're just
gonna try okay that's all we can do all
we can do is try so um yeah let's play
what where did we leave off what was the
last section and now we're starting to
see things because obviously that ship
has liked the way to get asked then
weird hallucinogenic gases all I've put
it down too
okay so we saw this last time
where are you taking me now why would I
say
okay pretty clue let's go tell me where
we're going
damn it
it's gonna be cold in there
where are we going hopefully we get to
escape because the dude will start to
like hallucinate or something
fingers crossed pretty please can I can
end up in here piece of wood oh it's
fine
didn't mean to threw a spanner in the
works
don't even know what you're doing you
just do whatever he tells you don't you
yeah that's why you beasts a ceaseless
you would be call is like I know you can
change their personalities but if they
actually changed their personalities
because they said different things based
upon your actions I wonder if that
happens it does but I wonder if it does
be kind of cool at the way that they
react to things
or even my little things like that idle
animations maybe in the future that's
way too much effort for a forum are
slowly game developers okay this way
this way it is strange of the camera
angles changed so you were passing like
the forward arrow and then the camera
angle would change and suddenly she
starts to walk backwards because
forwards is backwards and I'm like wow
what's happening Oh
all right come on show yourself
he's it's not a man it's just a heart on
a stick
these [ __ ] places first
you only just realizing this now away
rather hat
look at this Maidan Sigma Dan or madam
cuz I realized that I was calling it
Medan I think most other people call it
but mad Dan what are you talking about I
don't want to hear anything from you so
I keep talking too much
didn't get me though did it no wait can
I go here
is there anything even over here
go down come on what fine I just wanted
to look and just wanted to look in the
drawer but okay fine just carry on
walking
oh Christ oh Christ that guy that guy's
probably still back here with us I mean
this is the airship you go stays on the
ship
we've no idea what you're talking about
I bet he kind of feels safe knowing that
he's with a lady as sassy as me you know
look she's so brave she goes why up
close to him
where did all your friends go I don't
know what the [ __ ] this is all about but
we got to keep moving and five olsun now
I would feel more safe being around
someone like her
screaming corpse also just get your fit
keep the corpse a cream cotton
was it caressing the picture of the lady
oh look this is one of these again
excuse me
that was mine - look at that the game
has told me that I should look at these
pictures
don't push me away from it
the closet board Alan
she's seeing things I mean he's getting
pretty freaked out so he's probably
standing
yup the hell
wow that's okay cuz now we get to go
back and have a look at the BJ oh sweet
amia flashlight
Go Fish
okay told me nothing
but we just going back the way that we
came
creepy hand
what are we going out
about display again
creepy hand
no could be hand
where did his body go though
yeah that's a little bit strange I mean
if this is just ghosts and stuff why is
his body disappeared
oh hey oh my yeah damn it
[ __ ] see oh okay good I get another
chance
Thank You game the first time you give
me a second job there
I guess cuz that's the only thing I
could do that
it's like our fine New Egypt you can't
do QuickTime stuff well I'll let you do
it again
but that can be a good sign Oh
I am still quite anxious that there
barefoot oh look this is the place where
in the beginning of the game if it's not
I think it is
what I've been doing here I feel like we
shouldn't go this way have a look
Charles sorry Charles
I'm gonna check around cuz I think I
could go to the left over here
because I know that I went in there as
the other guy and I died so I feel like
if I don't have to I won't go into that
place but I probably have to don't I
oh I have myself a knife well I'm glad I
won here even though last playthrough I
said that I wasn't gonna use weapons but
I feel like I can trust bliss more than
I could trust the other dude I don't
know she's at my truck she's a very
level-headed lady
to the virus
place the door is that way
laughs don't die with me
[ __ ]
oh look he's still back Brad you could
be our way out be our hero
why was he hiding buck up
this is just embed the whole entire time
[Music]
or Harry
we gotta [ __ ] by look at
baby
we'd be look it up I need to be
[Music]
[ __ ]
nice pajama bottoms you too our best
foot why I get so anxious I just like
one of my biggest fears just something
going through my foot because I feel
like that arch weight of your foot it's
very thin and anything could pierce
through it and just it just freaks me
out you didn't get a look at this last
time
crossed our only are strictly no
authorized entry to guarded areas do not
leave post okay
is that
what even was that
was that digesting on time chapter Oh
well after right-left a rat we're going
right because that's the way that the
light is telling us to go oh Jesus
Christ you see that that's a body
hanging there isn't a move
okay that was Brad that was pretty
spooky it took me a little while to
notice it that's why it was so cool okay
we're here you can take it to him
apples nope I bet you it's gonna be gone
now the body Oh No
okay still there he has not noticed that
body has he
I can't remember how to walk faster I'm
holding shift it's not really doing
anything controls now
whatever
oh that gas does not look good let's
just go this way false we can okay get
ready for the hallucinations guys
they're coming
oh not through that door
yep
that's a lot of people haha yeah we
walked into a pretty interesting room
they were terrified as well see they're
like dying from fear it's not just from
killing themselves from seeing things
actually they've seen something that
scared them to death
there's a baccarat here
great perfect
yes day
[Music]
I mean for coward he's not not cowardly
do it do it do it now okay
w I love her I tells me how to move
forward
oh okay yeah sure yeah mm I hate oh boy
oh boy wait I could have opened that
door
oh wait stay calm okay
what if it's someone that we know I'm in
that barefoot too so like it could be
oh no they're not friendly they have
gone
wooof proud of you proud of you oh yes
it's up in this door because it closed
on my side yes we see what's I will wait
dude I'll just click in
right
give me a [ __ ] break
don't guess
okay well this was a lovely trip to the
bathroom
hopefully you can bump into colas
is that really bad that you can hear
like there was this
one respirator one filter rejected
pervert young already has a gas mask
find out
so people were trying to get a gas masks
ah
but
what
it smells like garlic mustard
a quad narrator through hearing the
smell of garlic
eat something that help me get up there
I mean I know you probably could you
know climb on those pipes what's this
can you not push this at the box come on
the game said that I could click
without this immersion okay oops wait I
think there's a room back here let's
just scoop out
okay now that's just vindictive I have
my teens on the fingers I have my
fingers on the keys it's just it's not
working for me guys it's just too great
and to be fair I don't play games on PC
often so I think if i had a controller
maybe are we different although i said
that's the first me but it was it
controls all right we're let's just stop
making excuses and just say I'm bad okay
okay deal with it Alex Juliet hello
ooh
come back I went to go in the room
anything in here for me to check out
hola one of these Premonition things
are we gonna get saved eventually our
hell yes okay this we get just stay
alive long enough try and find the top
of this ship and not sure when but
sometime in the future someone will come
and get us
who's that who's there
get away
okay Brad
a life jacket
okay here
Karia no no I'm not hearing this I'm not
hearing this I'm not hearing you I'm not
hearing you okay
well as those of stuff to make out here
skeletons skeletons
skeletons
skeletons sort of altercation
sir you asked to be kept informed the
radio situation we attempted outgoing
messages at front in terms of no
response we were able to pick up in
direct messaging traffic until oh one
for 40 hours however there has been no
further incoming messages tracking since
that time it's possible that our radio
equipment is faulty
so
probably there is a radio on the ship
somewhere but we don't know if it even
works oh look a spanner I can get
spanner no one's stopping me pick up
this spanner sorry man
see this was me this is a hanging
skeleton we're supposed to see this he
notices
we have a spanner
now let's drop down Alex
Julia does he know they've been
kidnapped just just get down
though the dude with the phone ha
he dropped his spanner away oh she's
probably just in case quick time no
quick time seriously on that
okay I'm very surprised
there's quick time on a lot of things
but not on the bit where he had to
this game doesn't like be speaking
yay bread okay they found each other
hopefully I don't know what's going on
here my man
well if you got their eyeball it say
pilot Ebola it's a bullet
this was less
rats
she had been a pretty bad father come on
Team let's wwww digit visitor jujube eww
don't kiss him don't isn't about
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
Hey
i snotted
that was so intact
I snorted
ah
[Applause]
dddddd do you do TV
scheisse this oh this is pretty
that's far too nicely
okay come on flip let's go do some
ballroom dances not right Oh Papa my
blood yeah no place is perfect just like
no person is better
you have a nice bloody door and it's
open it's way to keep your head on
straight
yeah I mean just just forget that you
saw a bunch of dead people and doing
Brad
okay so we are eventually gonna end up
outside again could be bad
what about Dee
Oh
so I'm guessing we've lost our knife now
because it went in this skull of that
skeleton I wonder if we could have died
there can someone let me know in the
comments if you have seen her die though
can you let me know because I want to
know if I kept her alive or or not
[Music]
we're leaving
we're outside
oh it must be nice to be out there
now she's gone great from the stress
why don't you go back in oh she's
confused cuz it's come back to how it
normally looks yeah
but I don't know if I would have gone
back in
let's what's done is done I guess should
we have a look and see if this is still
a pass get blood
Gold chemical leak of God no we need to
get out of here
why did we do this
I think I need to find something to this
Oh
how is she still saying so level-headed
she is like the coolest I'd be freaking
out so much and I have a nest thing
come on just a bag I'm draggin what is
wrong with this frickin game dude
drag drag drag drag check broke it's
broke hopefully I don't have to open
that
what are they holding
is that what I need
I don't sing that
a patrol vehicle got two walks with no
tools in need
it's broken wise there's still
electricity on the boat then what just
happened
hey it's bad Brad no glasses with all
cotton socks
right
hey what's wrong Oh scheisse appetizer
balls
Oh
Oh No
I don't even want to play anymore No
[Music]
Oh
I am actually annoyed though I'm so
annoyed you don't know don't tell me I
don't know do out I'm annoyed okay is
this the same place that we were at
earlier yeah is she's having like a
flashback but he's
dad it's her boyfriend not the dude that
she saw earlier
what's the pendant man is it gonna be
Harun
yes there is
Oh
of knowing that excuse it's too much
it's happening maybe I should have
encouraged I don't know there's a very
quick is right now
[Music]
on
the one he was drowning which was not
her boyfriend so I think I should have
encouraged I don't trust myself anymore
guys I got this cold I don't trust
myself I don't know what I'm doing what
am i doing what
you okay
Thanks
I could have drowned
we got to get away he's still around
that guy
[Music]
I mean I guess she doesn't want her
boyfriend to be Killary this
yes scary too much stuff is happening
all at once I feel a bit overwhelmed
right now hey Brad
you're a Killa I don't like you anymore
you want to surprise me with the whole
pirate adventure then I gotta say it was
a good idea no it was I mean it's funny
I think it's funny but I think the guys
you hired are taking it a little too far
maybe and don't be cheap you get you get
these guys that are not cream of the
crop they're taking it a little too far
you don't get my drift so if you want to
feel free to pull the old plug get rid
of these guys I'm with you I mean these
guys are [ __ ] crazy they're chasing a
trap the ship
Oh
[Music]
Julia okay a little bit more it
something
who
somebody's [ __ ] yeah
[Music]
go in there
my to all officers captain Ford has
ordered that the consumption of alcohol
strictly forbidden your alcohol Russians
have you provided you at a later date
yeah I mean I guess they've seen tragic
things and they're not allowed to drink
this or as a way
sure that's let's take a little candle
with us why why not it's like hmm very
sturdy very nice like the candle
Oh
again you have a candlestick as our
weapon right people use candlesticks as
weapons
like include Oh
he obviously has never played
if anybody knew what the hell was going
on in this place it would have been a
captain mm-hmm you think
I wouldn't be so sure
probably not much of a practice with a
preacher guy yeah she said no I'll come
on these guys he's own little secret
stash
okay let's go we have a we have an evil
spirit well this first I can read things
there's some of the P right I can't I
think it was yeah I should really take a
look behind this door shouldn't should
what should I
yeah I should
all right
so how do i pry the similar the child
question
and when we check the room
come on con Matt
my neighbor bored Oh No I still have
junk
oh look same room but that was no help
what about this around here I open this
door
how did you do this
water purification plans
although for these combination things
honest on
ah you little butt
Dook
wait whoa that's the best they were on
he's still not helping me in my search
for a crowbar
Boop
fine what are we gonna do then can't use
that can I
it's got some heft at least oh nothing
door we could use the bloody candlestick
[Music]
wait she said Donnie she's a con man she
said
oh no Connie
[Applause]
[Music]
hey Tillich's present
oh my god she is chasing up
oh my gosh hey hey
no I press do you guess
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
she is something else
hahaha
frickin run I hate hidin it's just not
gonna work we just need to run man
Haydn's leo is find ya
see I think we were right to run thank
you
I don't know they could tell me what you
would have done w walk you know I am the
worst I am the absolute the absolute the
absolute I just I hang my head in shame
awesome
shame
so Bob we've got to go to no three-lap
screw this I can't play anymore I'm I'm
wish to about this um let me know if you
want to find out whether I kill everyone
in the entire game um that can be fun
good MIT how you feeling about the way
that I'm playing I um kind of don't want
to hear but I also do want to hear
anyway have a lovely day or evening
gives us a thumbs up if you enjoyed let
me know that you want to see more and
that you are entertained because that's
why I do these things okay how was your
evening
good bye